hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
we have the best five announcements from
today's google i o 2016 keynote it was a
pretty quiet keynote as far as like new
physical product announcements go but
there was a lot of cool stuff also shown
off so we got plenty to talk about
number five is android n improvements so
the android n beta dropped today not the
developer preview now we're on to the
beta i have it installed on my nexus 6p
and in theory you can drop this on your
main device and not have to worry about
any stability anymore and uh so far so
good so there's some performance
improvements with the vulcan api and a
new compiler there's some security
improvements as well and a couple of new
features most of the stuff here we
actually already saw with the developer
preview when that first came out and i
did a whole video about the developer
preview already so i'll leave a link
below the like button if you want to
check out all that's new with android
but now we have a clear all apps button
in the top of the multitasking tray a
bit of an improved multi-window support
and it'll also smartly remove apps from
the multitasking carousel that you
haven't used in a while there is still
no new name
but they did open a website where you
can now submit a suggestion
for the name of the os
uh i feel like they're just teasing us
at this point i'm pretty sure they
already have a name in mind and they're
just gonna wait till someone submits
that name so they can say that they're
taking our suggestion or maybe they're
just messing with us there's also
android wear 2.0 it's not shockingly
different but it is much faster and
it'll also let you add complications
from any app on any watch face so your
watch faces can be super custom now and
will also run completely independently
of your phone which is awesome number
four is the google assistant so it's
sort of like a next-gen enhancement to
what we already know as google now so
google now already does a ton of stuff
it already has all these cards and gives
you all this information before you even
ask for it but it's also a really good
voice search assistant essentially
google has been working with machine
learning and making this voice search
part a lot better so you can already go
okay google
who is the head coach of the los angeles
clippers
doc rivers is the head coach of los
angeles clippers and then you can say
okay google
how tall is he
he is six feet four inches tall so it
kind of uses the context of the previous
question to know we're still talking
about doc rivers it's kind of
conversational and you're supposed to be
able to use google voice search as if
you're just talking to another person in
the room with you you kind of already
know you're talking about and you just
flow the conversation that's the idea is
they're trying to make this new google
assistant even more conversational the
assistant is built into an actual new
physical product we saw today called
google home so it'll come out next year
it's this little white cone that you put
in the corner of the room and
essentially it's a wireless speaker with
all the voice recognition technology
from google so you can ask it to play
music or cast to your tv via chromecast
or you can just answer questions from
you know what's in your calendar what's
in your email or just google anything
that you would look up with google now
it just kind of becomes this hub of all
the electronics in your home or at least
in that room so it controls your
thermostat can control your lights you
know whatever you want to hook up to it
it'll work some people have mixed
feelings about you know a little white
box in the corner of the room that seems
to know everything about you and talk to
you and answer your questions
kind of seems to me like the future
though i kind of like the idea kind of
sort of reminds me of the computer from
star trek number three is the two new
google messaging apps alo or hello hello
hello and duo and these are going to use
the new google assistant and all the
machine learning so lo is the text
messaging app it has a bunch of new
features it has something called whisper
shout so i'mma just type yay and throws
a smiley face in there
now watch rather than tapping the send
button he slides it down to whisper
and slides it up again to shout so
that's pretty much like facebook
messenger but something really cool that
it does do is called smart replies
essentially it'll start to predict what
you might want to reply to someone's
answer based on what was sent to you
whether it's a question or a picture
by analyzing that question or looking at
that picture and then producing a list
of a couple of canned replies that you
might want to send back so that seemed
really cool and they gave a couple of
examples on stage might have been a
little cringe-worthy i don't know if you
see a picture of a piece of food and
then you say
nice food you know it's just kind of
looking at it and putting the name of
what it saw in your reply message but
it's still really smart and shows a lot
of what google's been learning i'm just
picturing an entire conversation of just
smart replies going back and forth smart
reply smart reply smart reply while you
never actually say anything to each
other
it's the future you can also have a
thread with the google bot so you can
actually ask it the same sort of
questions you would actually ask google
now and get suggestions and answers
stuff duo is the video chatting app it's
just video chatting so it's encrypted
from end to end it's based on your phone
number like facetime and it has this
feature called knock knock which is
essentially it lets you see the camera
of the person who's trying to video call
you live before you even pick up so they
can kind of like look into your phone
and tease you into picking up the video
call or something like that it seemed
really cool at first like a fun cute
idea but then also
perhaps a little bit creepy you could
see how that might go wrong like during
an important business meeting getting
like a weird call and someone like
trying to get you to pick up so i
imagine there's probably a way to turn
this off anyway those are the two new
messaging apps you can get on your phone
this summer alongside the messaging app
you already have on your phone and
alongside hangouts which will also
continue to exist separately so i guess
my only question is why couldn't they
all be bundled into one app
maybe they could have i guess they kind
of forgot about that whole unifying
messaging experience thing they were
working on a while ago
oh well number two is daydream so this
is virtual reality in android so you
already know virtual reality it's
already on facebook video and youtube
videos 360 degree stuff
google street view stuff like that
essentially starting with android n you
will now have all the ingredients for vr
built into the core of android there are
some android phones that could do vr
before but they were built into apps or
built into the third-party skin like
samsung's skin to fit in that headset
that they did that wasn't built into
android that was built into the skin
android n it'll be built into the os and
there's going to be a certain spec that
you need to meet starting next year in
order to be considered a daydream ready
phone so that'll include you know
certain grade sensors certain socs to
keep performance high and to keep
latency to a minimum i imagine certain
resolution display you want a good high
enough resolution screen and these
daydream ready phones will work with
their reference hardware so google is
this fall coming out with their own vr
headset that you can put android phones
in and its own remote control and they
did give us a little bit of a demo of
that and that's pretty much it it looked
really cool uh obviously the vr game is
evolving fast that's pretty much all we
know at this point but it is a lot of
exciting stuff and number one last but
not least is instant apps
i think this was my favorite thing of
all of google i o it kind of came as a
surprise but it's the ability to open
apps that you don't even have installed
on your phone instantly b h photo and
video has a beautiful android app but i
don't have it on my phone because i
don't shop for cameras every day
now if i'm searching for something
specific like a camera bag i can still
get that same experience
with one tap
the app opens up right to the bag i want
to buy
technically this is a deep link to the
android activity b h wrote to display
this product page and that's all google
play needed to download
i can also swipe here and see more
details about the bag
now when i added to my cart the
animation there it was pretty slick and
at checkout time android pay works
just like if i had the app installed i
don't have to pull up my credit card or
type in my name and address with android
instant apps i'm already signed in and
i'm ready to pay so that's pretty
awesome that's kind of like i said it's
legit it's building just the parts of
the app that you need in front of you
downloading just the parts that it needs
to show what you want to do on the app
and then as soon as you're gone you're
gone it's like you never had to install
the app in the first place it's kind of
like taking the mobile web to the next
level i feel like this could be awesome
there's already plenty of sites that
have a website and an app but the app is
way better so you just wish everyone
could use the app but not everyone wants
to go to the play store and download
something and then install it and then
start to use it if you could just use
the web app experience to a high quality
every single time that's just basically
what this does instant apps i love it so
there you have it that's pretty much
everything you need to know from the
google i o 2016 keynote feel free to
share this video for anyone who you feel
might find this information useful major
takeaways from this i would say are
one
vr
is everywhere
messaging apps
are kind of also everywhere
machine learning is incredible
and google is kind of basically skynet
at this point
in like the best possible way thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace